t'as le bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur arte france les
enseignants qui vont devoir débourser un
euro par test le reste à charge qui est
appliqué par l'assurance maladie comment
ce que vous avez accueilli cette mesure
c'est délirant en fait on est en
première ligne puisque depuis les
annonces de diar soir on n'en confirme
notre notre présence pour maintenir un
téléfilm d'éducation main venu et nous
l'ouverture des écoles à temps plein
avec tous les élèves on se rend compte
que effectivement le nombre de classes
fermées là a ajouté
depuis depuis janvier il augmente de
façon régulière le l'école a un rôle
dans la diffusion de l'épidémie on ça
qu'on s'est aperçu que la période des
vacances avaient avaient permis de
ralentir la diffusion de fin la
diffusion du virus pour qu'on se rende
bien compte que ça circule dans les
dents lait dans les écoles et là bas en
fait donc là la campagne de tests qui a
démarré en janvier de tests pcr
elle est tellement peu efficace que
finalement les enseignants qui en ont
profités ont eu peut-être un un test et
donc du coup ils ont su que pendant 24
heures ils étaient positifs ou négatifs
les tests salivaires effectivement on
commençait à se mettre en place
notamment dans le monde département dans
le dunkerquois qui étaient
particulièrement touchés mais mais on
n'a pas de retour de ces campagnes de
tests on s'aperçoit en plus que toute
façon n'a pas suffisamment de personnel
mais pas le personnel médical pour
encadrer cette s voilà donc on est
vraiment on est vraiment inquiet et
alors cette annonce est la goutte d'eau
quoi surtout que là on parle de test
mais ce qui nous intéresse c'est tout
simplement la vaccination c'est ça dont
on aurait parlé et justement ça en est
où 7,7 cm vaccination concernant la elle
les enseignant es les professeurs qui
sont comme vous le disais en première
ligne dans cette épidémie commis 19 août
et on est le 19 mars
monsieur mise éducation nationale nous a
annoncé que à la fin du mois de mars
tous les enseignants auraient pu
bénéficier d'une vaccination en tout cas
une première injection
voilà il nous reste onze jours mais pour
l'instant aucun enseignant a pu
bénéficier de cette vaccination
aucun alors pour l'instant le
gouvernement donc misé sur le dépistage
comme on disait avec cette campagne de
tests salivaires à ce qu'elle a
finalement était bien anticipé par le
gouvernement cette campagne non nous les
retours qu'on a pu avoir je vous parle
depuis bayonne à 50 km de dunkerque
on a eu quelques informations à la à la
fin des vacances scolaires donc au tour
du 4 et 5 mars avec une campagne de
tests salivaires dans des écoles du
dunkerquois la semaine du 20 mars avec
une volonté important puisqu'il y avait
objectif de faire après c'est presque 2
min est le le lundi et le pardon le
jeudi le vendredi
il s'avère que on n'a pas de retour de
cette campagne de tests donc on ne sait
pas comment ça s'est passé notre
inquiétude c'est je le disais on sait
que l'on n'a pas lé personnel médical
suffisant puisque on va faire appel à
des infirmières scolaires qui n'ont
d'autres missions dans les écoles dans
les collèges dans les lycées pour venir
faire et du coup ça veut dire qu'elle
mette de côté ce travail qu'elles
qu'elles font prévalait alors on a
entendu les déclarations du premier
ministre hier soir les écoles et les
collèges vont rester ouverts pour
justement donner aux élèves et aux
enfants une
voilà une éducation soutenu on se
rappelle du premier confinement il avait
eu un décrochage de la part de beaucoup
d'élèves est ce que vous comprenez cette
mesure alors effectivement j'ai juste
préciser à votre propos les lycées aussi
restent ouverts mais ils accueilleront
les élèves en demies jauge toute façon
ils brident c'était le cas des collèges
dans le bassin de dunkerque et donc que
les écoles restent ouvertes
c'est une c'est une bonne nouvelle et
nous souhaitons que les écoles restent
ouverts c'est très très important on y
est attaché en revanche on y est a lâché
dans des serres dans certaines
conditions et la diffusion du virus
elle est liée notamment aux conditions
dans lesquelles on accueille les élèves
pas de masque en tout cas pas de masque
fournis par l'éducation nationale
pas de gel hydroalcoolique fournis par
l'éducation nationale des
infrastructures sanitaires dans les
locaux dans les écoles qui sont pas
satisfaisantes pas de possibilité de se
laver correctement les mains d'ailleurs
elle est classe évidemment il ya à
prendre en compte le fait que des
excuses et mangé un retour et j'ai du
mal à entendre ce que je dis enfin je le
malade donc gg faire comme ça c'est ça
aujourd'hui pas ce que j'expliquais sait
que c'est le fait que les écoles
ouvertes c'était très important pour
nous et on y tenait on était vraiment
très attaché à sa évidemment bien sûr
maintenant voilà tout le monde c'était
moyen c'est la possibilité pour les
enseignants se faire vacciner
et puis bien entendu du moins les moyens
en terme de personnel parce que là
actuellement le remplacement notamment
est pas suffisant et il ya dans
certaines écoles la nécessité de devoir
demander à des atsem des avs qui est que
ceux d'enfants en situation d'handicap
de prendre en charge des groupes ce qui
n'est pas acceptable
ou alors de brasser les les classes
qu'on les enseignants sont absents et
donc au risque de de faciliter encore là
dessus merci beaucoup en tout cas à
l'intérieur d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur et qu'on se crétaire du snu
fsu du nord le syndicat national
unitaire
des instituteurs professeurs des écoles
fédération syndicale unitaire